our next guest Y is a perfect person to
shine a light on for giving Tuesday with
more than 17 million followers on Tik
Tok alone he is blown up on social media
with videos of him surprising complete
strangers with gestures of love and
appreciation this summer I teamed up
with him for one of these
moments oh my gosh nice to see you
surprising you with um Vegas I don't
know if you want to come to
Vegas hope you love the show a it was so
cool to be a part of let's welcome Zach
known on Tik Tok as mty motivator
welcome to the show for having me
absolutely I love I'm obviously you know
I'm a fan of what you do but how did you
get into this so the name on social
media stands for MD motivator which
means medical doctor motivator because
during the co co in the pandemic I was
in medical school in Sydney Australia
yeah and when I say the pandemic a lot
of people really lacked connection and
felt alone and during that time I had
a uh combination of things that happened
to me I went through a sixe relationship
breakup medical school was challenging I
had ACL surgery there wasn't anything
particular you didn't get a break but it
was just a Breaking Point and it was
finally a time in my life where I saw a
blank slate who am I what's my purpose
what makes me happy and I just didn't
feel I was really in a hole and I had no
one to turn to so I started making
videos to find a friend to create
connection yeah and that's how this
journey started I started making
blindfolded hugging videos where I would
hug strangers because one night when I
was in Sydney Australia medal School in
the middle of the night I went for a
walk I didn't want to tell my roommate
what I was going through and I sat there
in the rain and these two women in their
late 30s they came up to me and they're
like what's going on and I was like
hysterically crying at the time and I
said nothing and they just sat there in
the wet cement and they listened to me
and the power of just having a stranger
hear me made me want to do that for
others so that's why I started
blindfolding hugging strangers if they
were going through depression or
heartbroken or felt empty or missing
someone I just cuz that pivoted my life
and never been able to reach them ever
again so if you're listening out there
in Sydney Australia I love you you
changed my life forever and I just
wanted to be the same for that oh my
what a magical start I'm not I didn't
know that's how it started that's how
started well what what was your first
video my first video was a poster in
September 2021 it said your vaccination
status won't change how much I love you
and that was a huge yeah and this video
wasn't about the VW as much as it was
about conditional love yeah at a time
when we really need the connection
absolutely so it it's very polarizing
but at that point it wasn't about the
polarization I just wanted to bring
people together yeah absolutely how
started love I love that well these
moments really are so powerful so just
check out how it can have a trickle down
effect watch this how are you my
daughter was the one with the little pom
poms on her head that came up and huged
you today so I just wanted to say thank
you because she's really then struggling
with depression and you call me new dat
today so thank you you she gave a really
tight hug she said I needed this I
didn't know yeah thank you so much it
made a whole difference to
her
like you I you say something I've heard
that you say something that is it's like
your mess equals the message right your
mess is your message yeah the mess is
your message I love that it's so simple
but effective it is and you find your
purpose in like the things you're going
through right and like although you
don't want you're going through
something you don't ever want to lose
hope and to know that what I went
through allowed me to be able to share
that whether it's the person in that
video or the daughter or the people that
watch it online who maybe are going
through something to just know that
they're not alone I've seen it several
times and I'm still crying over it's so
beautiful just how affected she is and
how much you don't know like something
that you do might affect somebody else
and impact them in a negative or
positive way you know into be grateful
for the people you have in your life
while you have them so I was able
fortunate to bring my mom here today
yeah Mama right there you got Mom in the
house if it wasn't for her I wouldn't be
here so everything I've learned is
through my parents my mom and my dad so
I just very beautiful and it's grown
Beyond you it's now bigger than you yeah
it's just it's it's been mindboggling
and then we recently started our own
501c3 called kindness is cool so we have
a charity that just launched about two
months ago so we're trying to really
scale this and bring into the school
systems and that's amazing do good yeah
and you already have these sponsors
people you know like the networking of
that right like on the with the
networking of that is so cool and you're
able to from that one night out there
with those two women that stopped you
like look at all the beauty that came
out of that and if we were all just a
little more vulnerable we'd realize that
we can relate and hopefully Empower a
little Kinder yeah a little Kinder uh he
is all about surprising total strangers
with acts of kindness total strangers
like our next guest who's a traffic
control officer in Detroit just look at
part of their meeting you want to buy
this mystery Jersey for a buck sure yeah
I can my duty right now oh what M are
you from Detroit yes I am born and R are
you a tiger fan of course tiger F yes
what time you work till tonight oh I'm
I'm here so I think say 11 we got a lot
going on tonight nuts cross and happy
Mother's Day to all the mom have a great
day enjoy your evening we want to let
you know that you got the thumbs up oh
my God are you serious we're going to
the
game right now you're sitting on by Theo
now my
my W going be that and you got 500 bucks
oh are you serious it's Mother's Day
weekend want to celebrate a mom you
don't even know right
now my gosh every time let's welcome
lenita
everybody oh it doesn't matter how many
times I watch these videos I cry every
time it's just the shock of it the
surprise what were you thinking in that
moment a miracle yeah it was a Miracle
because it it was it just the way that
everything happened cuz I you know I
don't know if he told you anything but I
kept trying to send him away and it was
really like I'm working yes I'm you know
not even that but it was just a lot
going on so
yeah in that moment though for for that
$500 to to be presented to me my son and
I had just prayed the night before cuz
my oldest son who's in college and
playing out of pocket you know he said
Mom I'm not going to be able to really
help the tuition I said no pay your
tuition don't worry about that we're
going to pull it together and we're just
going to pray and we prayed and the next
day that oh thank you Lord God thank you
Jesus I couldn't help it was a miracle I
know some people were saying well this's
only $500 but it was a miracle for me in
that moment that's incredible I want to
give you a list of things to pray about
for me you have a direct line to God or
something oh oh I did but it it it it
stamped my faith in that in that moment
cuz I was my back was against the wall
you know literally on a wing in a prayer
so just for that to happen and then he
was so persistent I mean I kept trying
to send him away why were you so why why
Lita well it was Mother's Day week and
we wanted to surprise the mom and all
she was doing the entire time was
blessing moms happy Mother's day and
happy Mother's Day to all the moms and
I'm like I need to talk to my Superior I
need to talk to my I'm like we're
getting you to the
game it's going to happen so it didn't
matter what the it was just we I wanted
to shine the light and show her energy
and just her love for people to the
world yeah I didn't know what it meant
to I mean I understand what viral means
yeah but I didn't understand what it
means to really go viral well that was
just the beginning for lenita two days
later she was invited to another Tigers
game and this time a walk onto the field
so check out what happened this is
incredible the people of Detroit that
watch the
video
donated and an additional
$50,000 for you and your
family way to go
Detroit thank
you Lord thank you Lord thank you Lord
thank you Lord like you did not expect I
didn't expect that and I was watching
and I thought well this has gone viral
so this would be amazing but I still
didn't expect it it was incredible oh my
word oh my word oh my word did you for
that right before cuz like no honestly
and this is the god honest Z no nobody
really knew cuz it's embarrassing when
you have a a debt that's just way over
your head so when they when they brought
the check out and see it it felt like a
dream so when I lift my hands and I say
thank you Lord you mean it that's why I
oh but with every breath in my body yeah
every breath in my body no I I do
understand that I was in debt before
Idol and then I went Idol and they like
you getting some money I'm like any
amount will
do right so what do you all want to both
say to people like on giving Tuesday
like what what do you want the message
to be for people out there I think the
biggest message too with the $50,000
that was raised was there was thousands
of strangers online that took their
hardare money put it onto this website
gave it to me gave it to her thinking
it's going to go to good the idea that
there's social proof that people want to
do good often times we just don't know
where to start so put good out into the
world and good always attracts to it be
kind lead with love lead with kindness
and you get blessed enough to be on the
Kelly Clarkson show yeah blessed enough
to be a part of your show your show
touches so many people and to use the
social media Outlet like that for good
you know like a lot of us parents are
always like ah get off get off get off
line that's like so good like to to use
that outlet it's for a good power you
know yeah oh God we are going to be
right back with what I'm liking I'm just
going to use these tissues a little
[Music]
[Applause]
more thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home